ce qui fait la singularité de
l'écosystème agricole français je pense
que c'est sa capacité d'innovation et à
la fois la richesse de ses savoir-faire
et leur complémentarité donc c'est cet
esprit qui nous anime et qu'il faut
soutenir pour renforcer notre
souveraineté alimentaire mais aussi
notre capacité d'export on verra c'est
aussi important pour notre pour notre
société et ne pas laisser d'autres tout
simplement innover à notre place la
France a d'ailleurs tout je suis marié
tradition et innovation et
principalement et particulièrement en
matière agricole et culinaire et on a
vraiment toutes les cartes en main
l'excellence de notre écosystème de
recherche le rayonnement de notre
gastronomie et bien entendu la place
centrale de notre agriculture sont en
terreau unique au monde on a toutes les
cartes en main pour créer une filière
française d'excellence dans un esprit
d'ouverture de complémentarité et
surtout faites de collaboration entre
tous les mondes le monde agricole le
monde de la recherche les acteurs
émergents et les pouvoirs publics
c'est-à-dire toutes les parties
prenantes autour de cette table je vous
remercie
très bien vous nous expliquerez tout à
l'heure comment vous faites si ça vous
ennuie pas monsieur du toit donc vital
mythe bonjour à tous
je tenais à vous dire que je suis très
honoré aussi d'être parmi vous en tant
que citoyen et je suis très heureux que
le Sénat saisissent du sujet de la
viande de culture viande cellulaire ou
quelque soit la manière dont vous voulez
l'appeler aujourd'hui parce que la
dénomination n'est pas fixée alors c'est
vrai la viande de cultivée est un sujet
encore méconnu il y a une élévation qui
suscite des interrogations légitimes et
j'espère qu'on pourra y répondre
aujourd'hui mais c'est avant tout une
nouvelle source de protéines animales
goûteuse saine positif pour la santé
respectueuse de l'environnement au sens
large et de ce fait un véritable enjeu
stratégique pour la France son autonomie
alimentaire et sa compétitivité dans les
10 prochaines années
peut-être quelques mots de présentation
sur sur vitalit et moi-même je m'appelle
Étienne Dutoit donc j'ai un parcours qui
m'a conduit de la finance au milieu
agricole où j'ai travaillé pendant 7 ans
au contact des agriculteurs dans le
domaine des biosimulants avant de
m'intéresser à l'agriculture cellulaire
j'ai ensuite cofondé vitamines avec le
groupe Grimaud en 2018 on va dire qu'on
a une histoire très singulière dans cet
univers de la viande de culture car on
est le seul projet directement
issu des filières agricoles
traditionnels en effet le groupe Grimaud
est une etie familiale située en
territoire rural dans les Vosges donc le
cœur de métier de ce groupe et la
génétique animale et la production
d'animaux reproducteurs
la pincrevettes insectes etc et il y a
des crevettes reproductrices et le
groupe Grimaud est donc un acteur
historique de l'élevage est parfaitement
conscient des enjeux actuels
compétitivité de nos filières face aux
productions étrangères nouvelles
attentes sociétales et diversification
des régimes alimentaires nouvelle
difficulté liées aux pandémie grippe
aviaire passe-partine africaine et
nouvelle difficulté il y aurait
chauffement climatique emploient des
artifications des campagnes
ce groupe c'est d'ailleurs diversifié
depuis une vingtaine d'années dans la
bio-pharmacie et la bioproduction c'est
finalement de sa branche qui est issue
la technologie et le savoir-faire de
vitamit pour la culture de cellules de
poulet et de canard donc notre objectif
est de proposer une nouvelle gamme de
protéines animales complémentaires aux
filières existantes avec un cahier des
charges extrêmement exigeant sur
l'empreinte environnementale la sécurité
alimentaire et la santé et bien sûr la
qualité et le goût
on s'est bien entendu poser la question
du sens de la viande de culture et de
son positionnement dans la filière pour
moi effectivement la priorité n'est pas
de reproduire la viande à l'identique
absolument un blanc de poulet plus vrai
que nature etc d'autant que la viande
brute est un produit culturel et que
nous sommes nombreux à ne pas vouloir y
renoncer notre vision est celle de la
complémentarité et on oriente nos
travaux vers la production d'un
ingrédient de poulet cultivé avec le
même goût les mêmes apports
nutritionnels que la viande
conventionnelle pour être utilisé dans
toutes les recettes de produits élaborés
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui on a parlé de
nuggets mais plat cuisiné pizza salade
etc les consommateurs demain auront un
nouveau choix possible les produits
issus de l'agriculture cellulaire qui
intégreront un régime alimentaire de
plus en plus diversifié et nous on veut
que ce nouvel choix il soit français au
plus proche de leur exigence en termes
d'empreinte environnementales de
production locale de sécurité de
sécurité alimentaire de santé et
évidemment de goût
on est très fier d'être dans la course
avec les plus gros projets mondiaux en
travaillant à partir d'une technologie
française brevetée et reconnue depuis
une quinzaine d'années on le voit
désormais la viande de culture se
rapproche chaque jour un peu plus de nos
assiettes un premier produit a été
autorisé à Singapour une pré-approbation
a été donnée aux États-Unis les coûts
revient baisse et les échelles de
production augmentent donc le moment est
parfaitement choisi pour s'intéresser à
cette thématique avec une question qui
pour moi est centrale quelle place la
France veut-elle occuper dans cette
nouvelle industrie je vous remercie de
votre attention
très bien
merci Monsieur ok je vous Monsieur le
Directeur je vous laisse la parole pour
voir le point de vue du scientifique
madame la Présidente Mesdames Messieurs
je vais être un petit peu technique dans
mon exposé je m'en excuse par avance et
je vous rappelle tout d'abord le
principe de fabrication de ce qu'on
appelle la viande de culture l'idée est
de prélever des cellules des cellules
souches ou des cellules musculaires sur
un animal vivant ou de travailler avec
des lignées cellulaires immortelles dans
tous les cas ces cellules se multiplient
dans un bioréacteur un bureau réacteur
de grande taille
ces cellules sont plongées dans un
milieu de culture et on obtient à la fin
du processus une grande quantité de
fibres musculaires et donc mon exposé va
être sous la forme de question il y a
d'abord des quelques questions éthiques
au départ si le nombre d'animaux
d'élevage doit diminuer en raison du
développement de la viande de culture
que va devenir la biodiversité animale
et qu'en est-il des animaux qui vont
rester qui vont être prélevés
régulièrement pour fournir des cellules
si on utilise des lignées cellulaires
immortelles on rentre dans la
problématique des OGM en ce qui concerne
le milieu de culture quelle est sa
composition il doit apporter des
hormones des facteurs de croissance
jusqu'à présent la viande de culture
vendue à Singapour contient du sérum de
vos fœtal comment recycler ce milieu de
culture pour diminuer les coûts
en ce qui concerne la multiplication
cellulaire la question de la stabilité
ou de la dérive génétique doit être
opposée et doit être étudiée enfin c'est
un processus consommateur d'énergie
puisqu'il faut porter les incubateurs à
température physiologique
en ce qui concerne le produit final y
a-t-il des résidus éventuelles du milieu
de culture dans ce produit final quelle
est la composition de ce produit final
quelles sont ses qualités sanitaires
nutritionnelles et sensorielles et tous
les scientifique qui ont publié de
nombreux articles indiqués sur cette
diapositive se pose ce genre de
questions il y a une autre question
est-ce que est-ce de la viande non selon
la législation européenne il y a des
avis variables selon les pays pour des
raisons politiques et ou religieuses
l'AFAO préfère parler de celle basful
c'est-à-dire aliments à base de cellules
les vegan et les végétariens pensent que
c'est de la viande mais les
consommateurs brésiliens que nous avons
interrogés pensent le contraire et en ce
qui concerne les experts de la viande
ils insistent sur l'idée qu'il y a
autant de différences entre le 20 et le
jus de raisin qu'il y a entre la viande
et le muscle puisqu'il y a une étape
importante de maturation c'est à dire de
transformation du muscle en viande qu'il
faut prendre en compte dans ce processus
une autre question est-ce bon pour
l'environnement il est tout à fait vrai
qu'il y a une étude de l'Université
d'Oxford en 2011 qui a répondu oui à
cette question mais depuis il y a
d'autres études qui ont un petit peu
tempéré cette conclusion
par exemple en 2015 il a été dit que
l'impact environnemental est plus élevé
pour la viande de culture que pour la
viande de poulet ou pour d'autres
sources de protéines il y a une plus
grande consommation d'énergie par
rapport à la viande bovine et cet
article la contredit la première étude
quand on regarde les gaz à effet de
serre qui sont produits par ce processus
c'est essentiellement du CO2 qui
s'accumule dans l'atmosphère au bout de
100 de 100 300 ans etc alors que
l'élevage comme chacun sait produit
essentiellement du méthane qui disparaît
plus vite de l'atmosphère un rapport
privé dont qui a été publié en partie
récemment montre que l'impact carbone
varie d'un facteur 5 suivant le type
d'énergie et assiste sur l'air certitude
de ces estimations il y a un autre
article de synthèse qui indique que
finalement il y a beaucoup de détails
qui ont été oubliées pour estimer
l'impact environnemental de la viande de
culture et certains insistent sur
non seulement la production de gaz à
effet de serre l'utilisation des terres
l'utilisation d'eau mais aussi sur les
services écosystémiques rendus par
l'élevage et il faut bien entendu
prendre ses services en considération
dans la comparaison
qu'en pensent les consommateurs là aussi
c'est extrêmement difficile parce qu'on
interroge les consommateurs sur un
produit qui n'existe pas donc finalement
quelque part
les réponses de ces consommateurs ne
sont pas très fiables néanmoins il faut
faire attention comment les questions
sont posées si vous demandez aux
consommateurs est-ce que vous êtes prêts
à goûter la majorité va répondre oui
est-ce que vous êtes prêts en consommer
régulièrement la majorité va répondre
non donc il y a une acceptation sociale
très variable selon de nombreux facteurs
et la plupart des consommateurs dans
leur grande majorité
voudrait que le prix de ce produit soit
inférieur ou égal à celui de la viande
conventionnelle
la majorité des consommateurs pensent
que a priori se produit ne serait ni ça
ni savoureux ni naturel
les consommateurs sont sensibles à des
arguments individuels sur leur santé sur
le plaisir de manger et bien que les
consommateurs notamment français
s'interroge sur les problèmes éthiques
et environnementaux de l'élevage cela ne
suffit pas toujours à convaincre puisque
seulement 18 à 26 % des mêmes répondants
pensent que la viande de culture est une
solution et c'est proportion et donc
relativement faible
j'insisterai sur l'importance de la
communication et même si c'est pas le
cas de nos deux entreprises ici
présentes le combat anti-élevage reste
une motivation de certains industriels
la dernière question que je voudrais
poser est la suivante pourquoi le
processus de recherche a-t-il été
inversé en tant que chercheur du monde
académique notre façon de travailler et
la suivante quand nous avons une idée
nous écrivons un projet qui est
expertisé si l'expertise est favorable
on obtient un financement et on
communique son nos résultats dans l'état
actuel des choses
il y a beaucoup de projets sur lesquels
les entreprises communiquent pour
obtenir des financements privés et nous
estimons que nous avons besoin
aujourd'hui d'une expertise collective
transparente par des organismes tiers
indépendants qui doivent avoir accès aux
résultats existants détenus par les
entreprises pour pouvoir se positionner
en attendant le principe de précaution
doit s'appliquer et je conclurai en
disant que nous organisons le prochain
congrès mondial des sciences animales à
Lyon fin août 2023 et il y aura une
session consacrée à ce thème et nous
allons demander nous allons inviter
l'ensemble des chercheurs qui
travaillent sur ce thème à exploser
leurs travaux à Lyon fin juin fin août
2023 je vous remercie
merci de salles deux ambiances sur la
sur les premières prises de
participation on va donc demander
maintenant au chef Thierry Marx sa
position enfin sa position en tout cas
c'est c'est réflexions voilà
on n'a pas beaucoup de recul alors je
suis là parce que évidemment je suis
chef étoilé vous me connaissez peut-être
sous ce titre là mais on a Paris Saclay
un centre de recherche et de
développement qui s'appelle le cefik
avec Raphaël au mont et évidemment on
est curieux de l'alimentation du futur
et on a regardé un petit peu dans le
détail avec le peu de recul que que nous
avons sur ce type de produit pour moi
j'ai du mal à appeler sa viande
mon sujet il est de pas tout mélanger
c'est à dire que gastronomie dans une
dans la gastronomie vous mangez une
histoire une relation à l'humain une
relation à un terroir etc dans
l'alimentation c'est plus compliqué
c'est à dire que on entrevoit dans ce
type de pratique encore quelque chose
d'ultra transformé pour les plus
modestes dans un pays où déjà on a une
fracture alimentaire au-delà d'avoir une
fracture sociale et bien c'est compliqué
c'est encore de l'ultra transformer pour
les plus modestes qui sont éloignés d'un
reste à vivre alimentaire suffisant donc
ça nous inquiète un petit peu parce que
là il y a pas de goût le peu qu'on est
goûté et notamment sur les Nuggets et
bien il a fallu pour leur donner une
saveur et une texture les aromatiser on
sait comment l'industrie aromatise tout
ça et
se restaurer c'est pas ça c'est vraiment
ramener dans l'assiette une histoire un
savoir manger un savoir-être autour de
la table la table et l'alimentation
c'est plaisir bien-être santé encore une
fois j'entrevois là
l'industrie agroalimentaire qui se dit
bingo on va encore rentrer dans la
théorie du low cost du tout pas cher
pour les plus modestes et ça ça nous
inquiète un petit peu on est curieux on
n'est pas critique à Paris Saclay on
regarde un petit peu ce qu'est
l'alimentation du futur mais on voudrait
pas laisser croire que la science et la
technologie pourraient répondre
simplement à l'impact environnemental et
un impact social la protéine animale
elle est surconsommer sur cette planète
on en mange dans de les conditions parce
que on a cru à la théorie du low cost du
tout pas cher et ça c'était une mauvaise
théorie parce que dans le tout pas cher
on a sur fabriqué de la protéine animale
et on a eu un impact sur l'environnement
qui était détestable mais aujourd'hui si
on ramène dans le flexitarisme 80/20 80
% du végétal 20%
protéines animales on peut s'apercevoir
que dans 20 ans on pourrait ramener à
quelques équilibres c'est notre
réflexion on n'est pas critique on n'est
pas arbitre non plus quand on prend la
casquette de Paris Saclay et bien on se
dit bah regardons pas de conflit entre
traditions et innovation avançons si ça
peut améliorer le sort de la planète et
surtout le sort du genre humain mais
avec beaucoup de précautions surtout
que à chaque fois qu'on veut nous vendre
ce type de produit on nous met en avant
l'impact environnemental et ça c'est un
peu gênant quand je vois ce qu'il faut
en termes d'énergie pour produire ce
type de ce qu'on appellerait de la
viande j'ai j'ai pas assez de recul pour
en tant qu'artisan et en tant que
chercheur là-dessus merci
la parole à nos deux rapporteurs Olivier
puis Henri Cabanel lyrics
merci madame la Présidente
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues quand j'ai proposé à la
présidente priman monter une audition
sur le sujet de la viande in vitro je ne
savais pas encore que cela se
transformerait en mission d'information
j'avais en revanche quelques idées
arrêtées je dirais plutôt réservé à
l'égard de cette innovation et au fil de
la quarantaine d'auditions que nous
avons menées je peux dire que mon regard
à quelque peu évolué sur la question il
reste que j'ai encore plusieurs
interrogations et mon corps rapporteur
Henri Cabanel exprimera bien ses doutes
qui sont loin d'être tous levés mais
force est de reconnaître que la France
fait partie du marché unique et que
l'autorisation dans le cadre de la
procédure nouveaux aliments sera donné
au niveau européen et non français dans
ces conditions la question des
probablement pas tant de savoir si le
produit doit être autorisé ou non en
France la réponse ne dépend pas vraiment
de nous Français en tout cas pas de nous
en tant que parlementaire
la question est plus de savoir un peu à
la manière des OGM même si le sujet est
différent si nous essayons de prendre
une petite part dans la compétition
mondiale ou si nous laissons les autres
le faire à notre place et arriver sur
notre marché sans que nous ne maîtrisons
la technologie les autres ce sont
notamment les États-Unis Israël et les
Pays-Bas j'étais justement ce lundi au
Pays-Bas pour aller à la rencontre de
deux des principales entreprises
développant ce produit en Europe nos
amis à Maastricht et mitable à deft à
côté de La Haye j'ai aussi eu
l'opportunité de rencontrer le ministère
de l'Agriculture néerlandais et je vous
dois dire que j'ai été frappé par la
différence d'approche là-bas un plan
public de 60 millions d'euros a été
débloqué pour venir en soutien à la
recherche dans ce domaine
je ne dis pas nécessairement que nous
devions suivre leur exemple la France et
la France les Pays-Bas sont les Pays-Bas
avec un attrait plus marqué pour
l'innovation et des contraintes en
termes de surface agricole utile et une
agriculture très intensive ayant
d'ailleurs causé de graves pollution à
l'azote et désormais une crise agricole
majeure mais tout de même cela interroge
d'autant qu'il n'y a pas que la viande
in vitro il y a tout un champ de R&D
comprenant aussi la fermentation de
précision que l'on sent frémissant
j'aurais donc deux questions
que pouvez-vous nous dire d'abord sur la
question de la complémentarité ou de la
substitution avec les activités
agricoles et notamment l'élevage dans
les hypothèses les plus optimistes il
semble que la viande de culture
représenterait seulement 0,08% du marché
mondial de la viande à l'horizon 2027
2030 cela semble peu mais si la
progression est exponentielle c'est déjà
significative des recherches sur la
production de viande in vitrol à la
ferme sont actuellement menées vous
semble-t-il crédible ou s'agit-il au
contraire de pures opérations de
communication par ailleurs dans quelle
mesure la viande cultivée pourrait-elle
s'insérer selon vous dans l’écosystème
agricole et agroalimentaire existant je
pense tant à l'amont avec les nutriments
nécessaires au milieu de culture car
Laval avec l'insertion ou non dans notre
industrie agroalimentaire ou notre
cuisine enfin j'aurai une dernière
question sur la gamme recherchée on
entend parfois que le coût fait obstacle
à ce que le produit soit accessible pour
les ménagement d'est ou pour les pays en
développement
d'autres au contraire insistent sur
l'intérêt du produit pour remplacer la
viande de mauvaise qualité à portée de
l'autre bout du monde et pour satisfaire
la croissance de la demande en protéines
animales par exemple la Chine qu'en
est-il selon vous merci
très bien Henri oui merci madame la
Présidente mes chers collègues je vous
remercie messieurs pour vos exposés je
réponds ma part aussi de deux questions
la première que je partage avec Olivier
Redman porte sur la question de
l'appellation de votre produit et de vos
procédés qui ont le voit suscite
beaucoup de débats d'ailleurs le chef
Marc Sana un a parlé
de ce que je comprends il faut
distinguer trois aspects premièrement la
terme générique Vienne en tant que tel
que nous banalisons tous par commodité
de langage mais qui peut être discuté
car il me semble que nous n'en sommes
pas encore à reproduire des côtes de
boeuf ou même des pièces texturées avec
des cellules musculaires de gras de Sein
et de tissus conjonctifs
pour autant les végétariens ne
consommeraient pas de votre produit qui
reste un produit origine animale
deuxièmement le nom de l'espèce en
elle-même dont on comprend qu'il serait
difficile de se passer pour
l'information du consommateur au regard
notamment des allergènes troisièmement
la forme du produit steak saucisse
carpaccio lardons etc cela nous renvoie
un débat que nous avons connu avec des
alternatives à base de protéines
végétales l'utilisation de ces termes a
été interdite par la loi pour des
produits non animaux mais le décret
d'application a été suspendu pour des
raisons de forme et on peut imaginer
assez facilement les contournements
on comprend que ces termes soient
intéressants pour perspectives aux
commerciales et pour l'acceptabilité des
consommateurs mais elles sont aussi
frais dans votre acceptabilité sociétale
car on voit que le monde agricole se
braque à cause de votre utilisation de
ces termes pourrait-on envisager
d'autres termes que celui de viande dans
ces hypothèses à quelle autre
possibilité d'appellation commerciale
pourrez-vous recourir ma seconde
interrogation porte sur l'impact que
pourrait avoir votre technologie sur la
concentration du marché de la viande
c'est d'ailleurs l'un des arguments
qu'emploie monsieur PHENO notre ministre
pour exprimer ses réserves il ne veut
pas dit-il de mastodonte de la viande
dans l'hypothèse de ces technologies ou
cette technologie se déploiaient à
grande échelle on peut imaginer une
concentration très forte dans ce secteur
dont l'amant était jusqu'ici
relativement décentralisée du moins en
France on voit d'ailleurs que les géants
américains européens de la viande comme
belle gargil JBS ou Tyson se positionne
en investisseur n'oublions pas que dans
un contexte de mondialisation
alimentaire un produit développé dans
des pays riches peut avoir des
conséquences importantes chez nous mais
aussi à notre bout du monde certaines
entreprises comme mozamith disent
vouloir un modèle décentralisé mais pour
aller au-delà de la bonne volonté
affichée des entreprises quelle
garde-fous peut-on imaginer par exemple
en termes de propriété intellectuelle
pour limiter la concentration de ce
secteur et surtout le coût de production
de la Vienne in vitro pourrait-il
vraiment baisser sans économie d'échelle
quatre premières questions
séries de questions plus exactement
peut-être monsieur morinforest voulait
apporter quelques éléments de réponse
sur ces questions
alors elles sont elles sont très vastes
peut-être commencer par les dernières
sur la sur l'appellation
effectivement vous l'avez dit en
préambule on utilise communivement le
mot viande de culture plutôt par
commodité il faut juste se rappeler que
les recommandations d'étiquetage seront
tranchées dans le cadre des procédures
de mise sur le marché d'approbation
réglementaire notamment à l'échelle de
l'Union européenne donc le dernier mot
ne reviendra ni aux entreprises il
reviendra peut-être dans le cours des
choses au final au consommateurs qui
aujourd'hui comme les différentes
alternatives protéiques par commodité
utilise des mots dérivés des produits
animaux pour les appeler ça c'est le
premier élément de réponse je pense que
comme vous l'avez bien rappelé il y a
trois niveaux le mot viande c'est pas
quelque chose sur lequel évidemment nous
en tant que société gourmet on est on
est cramponné comme vous l'avez rappelé
madame la Présidente on travaille sur
une alternative au foie gras déjà qui
est en lui-même une appellation
réglementée qu'on utilisera bien
évidemment pas dans nos étiquetages de
produits on pourra peut-être y faire
référence car il s'agit d'une
alternative
dans aucun cas notre produit ne pourra
s'appeler foie gras et on en est
conscient et on accepte complètement
cette contrainte maintenant le
l'expérience aussi gustative de notre
produit qui tue je rappelle et pour
revenir sur les propos de Monsieur Marx
pour nous s'inscrit dans une forme de
savoir-faire dans une forme de nouvelle
tradition en cours de construction a été
développé avec des chefs avec des
personnalités du monde culinaire dans le
cadre de nos développements de produits
et qui ont quelque part aussi reconnu
des propriétés sensorielles proches du
foiler et de fait à défaut de mieux
c'est compliqué d'imaginer une autre une
autre une autre appellation à court
terme pour n'utilisera pas sur nos
produits mais par commodité quand on
fait référence à nos produits c'est
celle-ci qu'on utilise
l'allergie vous l'avez rappelé c'est
fondamental vu que nos cellules elles
partent d'un prélèvement animal que le
consommateur sache qu'il consomme du
poulet de la crevette du canard du bœuf
car originellement il s'agit de
véritables matières animales même si
elle a été
produite d'une façon nouvelle
on parle beaucoup d'énergie à la
crevette par exemple c'est fondamental
de savoir sur l'étiquetage que on achète
un produit fait de cette crevette
la place de la filière je vais un petit
peu vite on pourra revenir sur toutes
ces questions
l'intégration de la viande de culture au
sein de de la de la filière plus
générale pour moi elle est évidente sur
la partie amont car il faut bien situer
la méthode de production qui consiste à
alimenter des cellules avec des
nutriments qui sont qui sont identiques
aux nutriments consommés par les animaux
sous une autre forme un animal va
consommer des tourteaux par exemple des
tourteaux de maïs des tourteaux de soja
les cellules vont consommer les mêmes
nutriments qu'on peut retrouver dans ces
tourteau évidemment sous forme
différente puisque les cellules n'ont
pas la capacité de mastiquer de digérer
les nutriments sous ce format là mais il
s'agit de la même source d'origine
agricole donc il y a une opportunité non
seulement pour développer une filière de
production de protéines en France mais
également d'intégrer le monde agricole
pour la fourniture de ce qu'on appelle
le milieu de culture qui est le
l'alimentation des cellules et là des
perspectives d'économie circulaire sont
fondamentales car on pourrait imaginer
recycler
des matériaux agitols non valorisés qui
pourraient devenir des nutriments
extrêmement intéressants pour les
cellules parce qu'il y a une plus grande
flexibilité sur l'acceptation des
cellules par rapport aux animaux qui ont
des contraintes justement liées à leur
système digestif je vais peut-être
lasser la parole sur d'autres questions
à Étienne si tu veux compléter il y a
beaucoup de choses
il y a beaucoup de choses effectivement
je te rejoins sur un certain nombre de
points
un point qui n'a pas été abordé c'est
effectivement les questions de propriété
intellectuelle de technologie etc
effectivement on est sur un domaine
complètement nouveau on est sur une
véritable innovation et d'où
effectivement la nécessité comme ça a
été rappelé de développer une recherche
publique en France sur le sujet et
d'avoir des entreprises qui développent
leur propre technologie pour ne pas être
dépendant de technologie qui viendrait
de l'étranger et c'est vrai que
aujourd'hui on voit des investissements
très important dans certains pays les
États-Unis Israël la Hollande on dispose
également ici de technologies et je
pense que c'est important dans cette
perspective long terme faut remettre les
choses en perspective en disant mais
qu'est-ce que ça sera nos consommateurs
nos moments de consommation dans 10 ou
15 ans de disposer deux technologies
françaises pour tout simplement être
autonome et proposer nos propres
produits au marché français donc il y a
un enjeu là-dessus et c'est aussi pour
ça qu'on est là aujourd'hui voilà pour
pour vous mettre voilà dans dans la
boucle et inciter à développer des
technologies propriétaires françaises
et d'ailleurs pour compléter les parmi
les
thématiques d'investissement des
Pays-Bas dont on a parlé du plan
d'investissement public pour développer
cette filière il y a une partie des 60
millions d'euros qui iront dans la
construction de plateformes de recherche
publique qui générera du coup de la
propriété intellectuelle qui générait
des données scientifiques en accès libre
qui pourra bénéficier à la fois mon
académique mais également aussi aux
entreprises qui veulent se lancer pour
quelque part aller aussi plus vite
et ça c'est fondamental de le faire
également en France il faut que le
milieu académique et de recherche
s'empare également du sujet bien sûr
Monsieur le Directeur oui je suis tout à
fait d'accord sur la question des
nutriments
il y a une différence évidente entre
aliments et nutriments mais vous savez
bien sûr que les nutriments qui
régissent qui résultent de la digestion
des aliments dépendent en grande partie
de la population microbienne qui a dans
le tube digestif et c'est très différent
par exemple entre un ruminant qui va
consommer de l'herbe et un monogastrique
et même au sein d'une même espèce le
profil des nutriments qui résulte de la
digestion va évoluer en fonction du
régime alimentaire par exemple donc
c'est quelque chose de très compliqué de
reproduire l'ensemble des nutriments
qu'on va mettre dans le milieu de
culture
et j'ai une autre question au-delà de
cette complexité c'est comment les
produire avec quelle méthodologie ça
suppose certainement
comment des unités de production en
amont et par ailleurs c'est pas les
nutriments qui me posent le plus de
questions c'est la question des hormones
et des facteurs de croissance qu'il faut
mettre dans le milieu de culture pour
que les cellules se multiplient
voilà quelques éléments et il y avait un
autre point que que je voulais aborder
concernant la recherche publique
comme nous sommes effectivement
interrogés notamment par la presse sur
ce sujet là nous avons effectivement
développé des travaux dans le domaine de
la recherche publique mais avec une
stratégie qui est qui est différente
c'est à dire que a priori comme vous
êtes en avance sur le plan technique on
n'a pas vocation à reproduire les
travaux que vous avez fait on a plutôt
vocations à
étudier cette problématique dans sa
globalité la globalité d'acceptation
sociale l'impact environnemental etc
les aspects techniques étant simplement
un aspect du problème et pour avancer
sur ces aspects techniques c'est vrai
que
il faut évidemment partager des données
ou partager des résultats pour que comme
le rappeler tout à l'heure c'est
résultat soit
expertisé contre expertisé par
différents
monde afin d'apporter un éclairage
complémentaire sur les travaux qui sont
faits jusqu'à présent
non non mais
je suis saisi un peu par le par le
propos et on parle depuis un moment de
viande et ça fait quelques années qu'on
nous parle de viande et il y a été
évoqué le sourcing de ses produits et
finalement tôt ou tard ça va finir par
doser ce sourcil qui est dans ce mot
viande moi je pense qu'il y a déjà un
trompe l'oeil presque une tromperie et
qu'on va vers une industrialisation
massive de l'alimentation donc un
appauvrissement encore plus fort
culturel quand j'entends parler de foie
gras ça une histoire quelques années on
a massifié la production de foie gras et
finalement le foie gras est devenu un
produit assez banal et on continue
là-dedans pour encore plus de revenus
plus d'industrialisation plus
d'appauvrissement culturel et c'est ce
qui m'inquiète un petit peu dans ces
dans ces travaux parce que sa
pourrissement culturel conduit à ne plus
pouvoir à un moment donné permettre de
revenir à une idée assez gastronomique
plaisir bien-être santé que doit être
l'assiette et un moment donné quand on
veut répondre et j'entends les enjeux
pour pas que la France soit à la traîne
mais finalement la France n'a plus le
pouvoir de dire ça stop non on en veut
pas chez nous donc en gros ça me gêne un
petit peu en tant qu'artisan maintenant
en tant que chercheur j'écoute le propos
mais je n'arrive pas à me déconnecter de
cette idée de déjà de vouloir massifier
encore plus l'industrialisation de notre
nourriture et donc de cette
mondialisation et de cette
approhérissement culturel encore une
fois on ramène tout sur la consommation
et sur le prix pas assez sur la culture
savoir manger c'est savoir être c'est
redonner du sens à son alimentation se
restaurer c'est quelque chose qui veut
dire quelque chose en termes de lien
social on l'oublie c'est c'est très
important sinon on peut effectivement se
nourrir comme à la Pitié-Salpêtrière
avec une perfusion
et j'ai pas de problème donc de m'amener
dans l'idée dans l'idée de fantasmer que
ce serait un pseudo foie gras une pseudo
viande donc je n'ai même plus le pouvoir
du sourcing du produit j'ai un peu de
mal avec ça par contre j'entends le
propos de dire il faut que la France ne
soit pas à la traîne de la recherche et
ce qu'on sache pourquoi on en veut et
pourquoi on n'en veut pas et ça ça me
paraît intéressant de ramener aussi
cette discussion sur le social et que
l'agriculture est là du sens et un sens
social et culturel et là on part encore
dans ce que j'entendais dans ce que je
lisais sur les 70 sur cette théorie du
low cost sur du tout pas cher renoncé à
la qualité en échange pas on fera manger
pas cher et on vous laissera croire en
fonction de ça que vous avez du pouvoir
d'achat c'est une manipulation des
masses moi qui me gêne pardon de parler
comme ça
juste pour rebondir sur le côté
appauvrissement culturel qu'on s'entende
bien on n'est pas là pour remplacer la
viande on est là on nous ce qu'on
propose c'est un nouveau choix pour le
consommateur qui aujourd'hui
diversifie ces sources de protéines
c'est déjà une réalité ça consommation
de viande diminue plus de végétale
demain des insectes point
d'interrogation à intégrer et là c'est
un nouveau choix un nouveau type de
protéines animales si le si le terme
viande vous vous questionne et c'est
complètement compréhensible donc il y a
pas d'appauvrissement quand on propose
un nouveau choix la deuxième chose c'est
sur la qualité des denrées alimentaires
qu'on va manger aujourd'hui il y a une
injonction et vous l'avez rappelé qui
est un petit peu paradoxal où on demande
à nos agriculteurs d'évoluer vers plus
d'agroécologie plus de qualité et en
même temps de maintenir des prix
extrêmement bas et si possible
d'augmenter la production parce que la
France n'est pas autonome en protéines
moi j'ai plutôt l'impression qu'il y a
une complémentarité entre les solutions
dites technologique qu'on propose
aujourd'hui pour accompagner une
agriculture qui est dans une transition
et qui évolue très favorablement en
France vers plus d'agroécologie ce qui
ne va pas faire exploser les rendements
il faut quand même avoir le courage de
le dire et qu'au contraire c'est
complémentaire de développer d'une part
une agriculture
agroécologique de qualité pour tous et
d'autre part en complément dans un
régime alimentaire diversifié d'autres
solutions d'autres produits qui sont
également de qualité
à la fois au niveau du goût à la fois à
la fois d'un point de vue santé et d'un
point de vue nutritionnel pour une
nutrition globale
très bien alors je vais laisser la
parole à la présidente du groupe
d'études élevage voilà et ensuite Arnaud
Bazin président de animal et société
merci présidente mes chers collègues
messieurs merci pour vos interventions
voilà je voulais moi revenir sur le
soutien de la viande in vitro parmi
lesquels on peut trouver des stars et
des grandes fortunes de l'acide Nikon
Valley qui finance le développement de
ce produit or certaines de ces fortunes
ont pu financer aussi des associations
que l'on peut qualifier d'animalisme mon
idée n'est pas de dire que ces
associations sont financées pour
préparer le terrain car je comprends
bien que la viande in vitro est
développée par des entreprises y compris
dans le secteur de la viande distinctes
de ces associations je ne dis pas que
c'est votre cas messieurs mais toutefois
je souhaiterais savoir si cela ne vous
met pas mal à l'aise de prospérer sur
une forme de dénigrement de l'élevage
qui est réduit à son seul impact
environnemental et en termes de
bien-être animal
l'explication scientifique est très très
éclairante et je vous remercie monsieur
le directeur car moi mes réflexions j'ai
l'habitude de les appuyer sur du
scientifique nous dit-on pas un peu vite
les aspects positifs de l'élevage qui
est d'abord de nourrir le pays et aussi
pour ces retombées économiques dans la
ruralité et également dans nos paysages
et c'est également la survie de la
biodiversité de nos paysages le pâturage
y participent ne va-t-on pas vers la
disparition de certaines races d'animaux
si ce produit venait à se développer à
très très grande échelle
de nos fromages AOP et excusez-moi je
pense tout particulièrement au comté qui
est le fromage de chez moi qui a été
reconnu le meilleur fromage du monde
l'année dernière
ça suffit
j'ai le droit d'être Chauvin
par ailleurs vous dites que votre
produit à vocation a remplacé le poulet
brésilien aux médicaments la réalité
économique de notre élevage aujourd'hui
c'est que l'élevage de qualité est
prépondérant en France qui les fragile
économiquement et ce n'est pas l'élevage
intensif que nous trouvons par ailleurs
dans le monde comme par exemple en Chine
aux États-Unis la viande in vitro n'est
peut-être pas la principale menace qui
place qui plane excusez-moi sur notre
élevage aujourd'hui mais il est vrai que
notre élevage n'avait vraiment pas
besoin de ceci
Arnaud je sais pas s'il y aura des
réponses à ça mais Arnaud Arnaud bazar
merci madame la Présidente et merci
d'avoir organisé cette table ronde où
j'ai entendu des choses déjà forte
intéressantes parce que je venais avec
certaines questions mais je vais y
revenir certaines
débuts de réponse pour votre information
notre collègue vétérinaire aussi dans la
vie voilà
dans une vie antérieure
donc une remarque générale et trois
questions la remarque générale c'est que
évidemment on s'intéresse ce matin à
cette entre guillemets viande de culture
mais je pense qu'il faudra jamais perdre
de vue de placer ce débat dans une
perspective plus large de d'apport
protéique pour l'alimentation humaine ce
qui a aussi les protéines végétales on
en a dit un mot il y a la fermentation
de précision ça va être le terme a été
employé tout à l'heure peut-être c'est
assez mal connu moins bien connu mais ça
à mon avis c'est une technique d'intérêt
aussi et de recherche et d'innovation
donc dans un
schéma général d'alimentation qu'on peut
très difficilement modifier puisque
c'est des c'est des choses qu'on reçoit
avec notre éducation dès la petite
enfance il y a quand même à préciser
vers quel modèle on va est-ce que on a
un modèle qui ne va pas évoluer et celui
qu'on connaît aujourd'hui avec une
partie tradition une partie entre
guillemets industrialisation ou est-ce
qu'on va petit à petit évoluer vers des
apports protéiques plus végétaux avec
peut-être des éléments de fermentation
de précision pas pour nos pays mais pour
des pays moins favorisés toute cette
question là à mon avis elle mérite quand
même d'être vu globalement ensuite sur
les trois questions que je me posais la
première question c'est et par
hiérarchie évidente d'importance
première question c'est la question
sanitaire et elle a été évoquée par le
représentant de l'INRA et tout à l'heure
on prend des cellules souches
pluripotentes il faut qu'elle se
différencie en cellule alors deux fois
pour faire du foie gras deux muscles
pour faire du muscle de bœuf ou du
muscle de poulet comme ça a été
également évoqué et pour ça il faut leur
donner un milieu de culture dans lequel
il peut y avoir en effet des hormones
des peptides diverses et variées des
intrants qu'aujourd'hui moi je ne
connais pas donc c'est ces éléments là
ils devront être pris en compte pour un
éventuel agrément il faut qu'on ait une
garantie de sécurité sanitaire
lié au milieu de culture on peut espérer
avec la rigueur des fermes des processus
qu'on règle d'autres problèmes
sanitaires qu'on a avec les produits
traditionnels comme la contamination par
des bactéries on en a malheureusement
des exemples de temps en temps mais on
se pose la question des intrants
qu'est-ce qu'il y a qu'est-ce
qu'on utilise vraiment pour ces
différenciations et ces multiplications
à part évidemment les nutriments dont on
a posé le cadre tout à l'heure et
comment tout ça va être pris en compte
dans la démarche d'agrément au niveau
européen je l'ai entendu mais moi
j'aimerais bien être éclairé sur toutes
ces questions là parce que s'il faut
quand même que la garantie sanitaire
soit assurée la deuxième question
c'était le bilan environnemental au sens
large il y a pas seulement les gaz à
effet de serre les effluents etc là j'ai
compris que aujourd'hui on peut pas
faire notre Dion parce qu'il y a du pot
il y a du contre donc il est tout à fait
urgent qu'on ait des éléments
complémentaires là-dessus des études
globales alors vous me direz sur des
processus des processus industriels qui
n'existent pas aujourd'hui mais qui va
falloir essayer de se projeter quand
même pour avoir au moins une première
approche une approximation
et la troisième question mais ça elle
trouvera sa réponse je dirais quasi
naturellement c'est la question
économique est-ce que c'est viable
économiquement c'est la question que je
me pose depuis le début maintenant moi
je n'ai pas participé à la levée de fond
de fond pour les startups donc je suis
pas très inquiet à titre personnel mais
je vois qu'il y a beaucoup d'argent qui
s'investit là-dedans donc il faudra
quand même que cette question économique
avec
l'éventualité d'y mettre d'ailleurs de
l'argent public en termes de recherche
on est à une première approche parce que
on va pas non plus investir à fond perdu
et puis ma conclusion provisoire très
provisoire je rejoins là dessus
Marie-Christine Chauvin c'est qu'on a
absolument besoin d'une démarche
scientifique
en dehors de tous les aspects polémiques
qui peut être qui peuvent polluer le
débat une démarche scientifique en effet
pour savoir si sanitairement il n'y a
pas de problème pour savoir si en terme
d'environnement le bilan est positif ou
pas après tout le reste c'est
consommateurs qui tranchera et
l'économie globale qui tranchera mais
pour ça en effet et c'est très
intéressant de le voir qu'on a eu un
processus de recherche inversé c'est une
originalité maintenant je pense qu'il
est pas trop tard pour bien faire et que
il est plus que temps que en effet des
tiers indépendants et sachant sur la sur
ces questions là soit mobilisées ça peut
être que de la recherche publique avec
éventuellement d'autres apports mais
pour ça il faut qu'il y ait des
initiatives de l'administration et du
pouvoir politique pour que on puisse
rapidement y voir clair là-dessus merci
merci je vais on va prendre toutes les
questions les unes derrière les autres
donc voilà
Franck montoger merci madame la
Présidente merci à tous
merci à vous quatre pour vos
interventions
je voudrais revenir sur le mot culture
du de l'appellation vient de culture
voilà moi je pense que la
nourriture le rapport à la nourriture
l'histoire que Monsieur Marx a évoqué
c'est aussi un trait de civilisation
le foie gras je suis un pays d'un pays
de foie gras je suis très très attaché
vous en doutez tel qu'il est aujourd'hui
le foie gras de l'Égypte ancienne parce
que parce que ça remonte à très très
longtemps n'est pas le foie gras
d'aujourd'hui mais avec ce que vous nous
proposez on est fondamentalement dans un
changement de paradigme
de rapport
civilisationnels différents complètement
différents à la nourriture voilà je vais
pas appeler à la rescousse Claude de
Lewis 3 sur cette question là qui a
écrit beaucoup de choses très très
intéressantes mais c'est exactement ça
auquel on est on est confronté donc
ce sujet votre sujet illustre aussi pour
moi la question de l'évolution du modèle
agricole de l'agriculture et de la place
qu'à le l'agriculteur producteur dans ce
processus avec ce que vous nous proposez
qui est en fait une industrie voilà
agroalimentaire on s'éloigne du modèle
que l'on connaît aussi sur nos
territoires pour aller une fois de plus
vers les agriculteurs producteurs
exécutant au service d'entreprise en
l'occurrence agro agroalimentaire voilà
donc c'est c'est vraiment
illustratif d'un choix de civilisation
qui n'est pas le mien voilà je vous le
dis clairement et je me crois parce que
j'essaie aussi de fonner mes analyses et
mes positions sur des données objectives
le plus possible
je pense que comme le monsieur de l'INRA
lindraule l'a dit il faut absolument
qu'on avance sur le le processus et
qu'on objective effectivement toutes les
données de ce de ce problème de cette
question là avec si possible notamment
sur la question environnementale et
climatique des études d'impact complètes
et pas biaisé comme on les a aujourd'hui
moi quand j'ai entendu que l'élevage
doit être complètement éradiquée parce
que il réchauffe l'atmosphère etc c'est
un des aspects de l'élevage mais c'est
pas le seul voilà il y a aussi des
impacts en termes de de séquestration de
carbone enfin je rentre pas dans le
détail voilà on a besoin on a besoin
aussi le citoyen a besoin de tout ça
pour se faire une idée et je termine sur
un point fondamental et là je rejoins
complètement les propos de Monsieur Marx
la question de l'accessibilité en termes
de coûts des des Français de nos
concitoyens les plus modestes aux
protéines et à la viande et une viande
de qualité voilà et ça ça pose la
question du pouvoir d'achat qui est qui
est évidemment lié au problème aux
problèmes dans son ensemble merci
Bernard buis merci présidente merci pour
vos propos donc deux questions la
première sur l'impact environnemental de
la vie en didro l'agriculture
aujourd'hui est en pleine période de
transition afin de limiter son impact en
carbone cela étant quels sont les
données actuelles sur l'impact
énergétique de la production de viande
in vitro un tel mode de production
Consulting moins d'énergie que l'élevage
traditionnel ou s'agit-il au contraire
d'une fausse bonne idée qui serait
contente productive dans la lutte contre
le dérèglement climatique et puis une
question concernant les conséquences
d'un tel mode de production quelques
jours avant le lancement du Salon de
l'Agriculture on peut s'interroger sur
les conséquences d'un tel mode de
production la viande in vitro en
laboratoire n'engendrerait-elle pas un
recul de l'élevage paysan dans notre
pays par ailleurs quelles seraient les
conséquences sur la gestion des paysages
et des prairies enfin que penser du
risque d'accaparement de l'alimentation
par quelques films firmes qui pourraient
demain de tenir pouvoir considérable
presque philosophique Laurent Duplomb
attention ça va déménager
madame la Présidente je veux ni être
objectif ni faire de la philosophie je
veux simplement me rappeler de ma
jeunesse ou dans les années 70-80 on
nous expliquait qu'après là on est 2000
nous mangerions tous des cachets ou des
cachets je crois et que l'alimentation
ne saurait plus un plaisir
depuis 2000 il me semble que c'est
exactement l'inverse qui est arrivé
c'est à dire que ce qu'on nous avait
promis 30 ans à vin avant était juste
l'inverse de ce qui s'est passé depuis
2000 le consommateur français et les
consommateurs sur la planète qui voit
l'agriculture et l'alimentation
française comme étant la plus
gastronomique du monde ont été sur les
circuits courts ont voulu des AOP en
volume une traçabilité des produits ont
voulu du bien manger et ont voulu sans
cesse des injonctions à l'agriculture
qui a essayé au fur et à mesure de ce
temps là de répondre à leurs exigences
et bien je vous le dis tout net sans
objectif je suis contre la viande in
vitro je ne vois pas quel est l'intérêt
pour notre culture pour notre pays
d'aller sur ces problématiques là la
première c'est que quand on nous dit le
consommateur sera informé belle sornette
comment on va t'en informer le
consommateur qui mangera un plat dans un
restaurant de la quantité qu'il aura à
l'intérieur de cette viande in vitro on
nous dit il faut plus de végétal
savez-vous
des territoires et des paysages
supprimer l'élevage en France ça sera
supprimé une très grosse partie des
paysages que nous vivons et nous aurons
véritablement des problèmes là-dessus
cinquième élément et je termine
là-dessus le savoir-faire le
savoir-faire et le patrimoine culturel
moi je le dis tout net j'ai pas envie de
vivre dans un pays où tout est aseptisé
j'ai pas envie de vivre dans un pays où
on porte un masque de l'eau à longueur
de journée je n'ai pas envie de vivre
dans un pays où on a remplacé les trois
mots de la République française de la
liberté de l'égalité et de la fraternité
par la peur la culpabilité et l'interdit
j'ai envie de vivre toujours dans un
pays libre dans lequel j'ai le droit de
manger ce que je veux et en particulier
de la viande de bovins vivant en courant
dans les prés et étant élevé par des
agriculteurs je crois que personne ici
ne tendant pêchera très bien merci
Laurent nous passons à Laurent saumon
la plupart des questions est déjà été
posées mais je voulais revenir sur
effectivement le côté bilan énergétique
de la production de la kilo de viande
j'allais dire une vitraux par rapport à
un kilo de viande naturel je rejoins
parfaitement je dirais ce qui a été dit
c'est que il faut pas confondre
s'alimenter se nourrir je pense que
effectivement le plaisir de manger c'est
aussi quelque chose qui est très ancré
dans notre culture et j'ai bien retenu
l'image de ramener dans l'assiette une
histoire je pense que si on oublie ça on
oublie notre culture et aujourd'hui on
est dans une société qui veut nous faire
penser qu'il faut oublier notre culture
ou qui revisite complètement notre
culture c'était bien dommage et puis
revenir sur la question que mon confrère
collègue est néanmoins amis Arnaud Bazin
imposé sur les additifs et en
particulier la consommation
d'antibiotiques dans ce process de
fabrication et de préciser parce que
vous avez parlé que néanmoins la culture
cellulaire permettrait de développer une
filière agricole pour la constitution
des substrats
par comment vous voyez cette chose là
parce que je ne l'imagine pas et
j'aurais bien voulu avoir des précisions
à ce sujet
merci
madame le Président
merci pour pour ces éclairages bon je ne
vais pas reprendre de nombreuses choses
qui ont été dites je pense que avec
cette culture in vitro nous sommes dans
l'étape suivante de l'industrialisation
de l'agriculture très clairement et avec
une
une des études d'impact je pense qui ne
sont pas encore à la hauteur je prendrai
simplement
trois études qui demandent à être
approfondi on l'a bien vu au niveau
environnemental il y a vraiment à voir
les impacts sur sur l'élevage qui est
comme ça a été dit a vraiment une grande
importance dans notre culture et au
niveau de l'environnement comme vue de
carbone comme préservation de la
biodiversité comme la prévention
incendie et j'en passe donc de nombreux
impacts au niveau environnemental qu'il
faudra prendre en compte sur la santé
effectivement par l'élultra transformé
et bien voilà c'est encore une une
marche supplémentaire
avoir avec les tous les additifs les
intrants qu'on aura dans cette viande in
vitro les hormones de croissance qui
sont quand même interdites depuis 1980
donc des impacts que l'on aura que l'on
peine à mesurer aujourd'hui on voit bien
déjà que nous sommes dans une
société où la malbouffe est très
présente et touche bien entendu les plus
précarisés qui n'ont pas forcément le
choix d'accéder à une nourriture de
qualité je pense que nous sommes là
clairement dans une nouvelle dégradation
de de la qualité et puis bien entendu ce
que reprenait monsieur monsieur Marx je
pense que là on a vraiment une rupture
en termes de culture la culture c'est un
terme polysémique
effectivement la culture avec
l'agriculture mais aussi notre culture
et là on est typiquement dans un
appauvrissement de l'humanité je pense
avec des enjeux que l'on ne pèse pas
encore aujourd'hui vraiment alors juste
valeur donc moi aussi clairement je suis
complètement opposé à cette nouvelle
étape qui sera peut-être franchi
ailleurs alors on a toujours on en
parlait hier de la compétitivité où
doit-on placer notre compétitivité je
reviens sur ce terme là merci
merci merci madame la Présidente moi
j'ai pas de doute sur la capacité
des sociétés et de la société actuelle
d'arriver à mettre point ce type de
produit et je le dis malheureusement
j'ai pas de doute je crois que c'est une
affaire de génération et quand on voit
la facilité avec laquelle
ce type de société arrive à avoir des
levées de fonds aussi rapidement et
aussi importante je crois que vraiment
on voit bien que là et dans les pays
comme les États-Unis dans les pays je
dis pas très avancé mais dans ces pays
où la recherche est
forte on voit bien que on y va je pense
inexorablement ma question c'est porte
sur est-ce qu'on va pas avoir quelques
sociétés dans le cadre du mondialisation
pas heureuse peut-être malheureuse mais
quelques sociétés qui vont tenir du
marché
je vois mal commun on va échapper à la
diversité de la production classique
pour aller vers des sociétés qui vont se
regrouper et vont avoir une force avec
du marketing et des moyens énormes pour
imposer leur choix et sur la recherche
parce que je pense que la recherche
publique sera très vite pris de vitesse
et moi je propose plutôt à la recherche
publique de s'intéresser aux
conséquences de de l'arrivée de ces
produits sur le plan sociologique sur le
plan environnemental des changements de
métier les
impacts sur sur la nature et puis notre
débat entre agriculture productiviste
agriculture familiale alors là vous
savez on va être très vite dépassé par
des notions qui qui vont tout faire
exploser
alors quand tu as imaginé le foie gras
du Périgord copié avec des cellules
souches je trouve que c'est la négation
de la société et comment on peut en
arriver là voilà merci
très bien Daniel Gremillet ensuite
Evelyne renaud-gard à bédian oui merci
Madame présidente merci aussi pour ces
quatre interventions moi je voudrais
revenir puisqu'on parle bien de la
viande in vitro sur un propos parce que
c'est une histoire à la française la
France et le pays au monde qui a su
garder la plus grande diversité animale
tout espèce confondue je le dis parce
que dans un avant d'être sénateur j'ai
présidé pendant 26 ans le comité
d'élevage au niveau national et tout ça
c'est le fruit de concours des
investissements publics et des paysans
dans tous les territoires on est le pays
au monde qui a gardé qu'à su garder la
plus grande diversité bovine bovine
Catherine porcine on peut tout prendre
on vient pas de nulle part je dis ça
parce que c'est essentiel c'est un
patrimoine génétique absolument précieux
le deuxième point c'est aussi la vie qui
nous rappelle à l'ordre
la France a fait le choix d'une en OGM
mon propos n'est pas de dire je suis
pour exogène mais mesurons les
conséquences c'est que nous avions de
connaissance et une capacité
d'intervention sur l'agriculture
se mentielle qui a été largement
appauvri et les chercheurs ont été
plutôt outre-atlantiques que rester dans
notre pays donc on ne peut pas ne pas
s'intéresser à quelque chose qui va se
passer à travers le monde je pense que
c'est essentiel et je remercie la
présidente de mettre ça à l'ordre du
jour parce qu'effectivement on a un peu
avant-gardiste mais tout va très vite
dans un passé aussi j'étais syndicaliste
à l'époque quand nos est parlé de
l'élève végétal il ne restait pas dans
les rayons plus de 24 heures
le lait de soja je vous rappelle
l'histoire j'y ai participé comme
d'autres
et aujourd'hui si vous êtes allé au ciel
en 2022
y compris des entreprises françaises
sans eau quand même problème mettre et
vente des produits
issus de production de protéines
végétales purement végétale sont
originales pourquoi je dis ça c'est pour
vous dire en l'espace de 20 ans quelque
chose qui était pas accepté même là les
paysans sans problème l'accepte donc ça
serait une erreur que la France ne
s'intéresse pas effectivement à cette
aspect des choses en termes de recherche
de mots je souhaiterais vraiment
je souhaite vraiment qu'on est une
expertise scientifique très poussée
parce qu'elle est essentielle et les
doit être indépendante du travail et de
recherche qui est fait au niveau des
entreprises c'est ces deux éléments qui
doivent être complémentaires et qui
devraient ensuite pour nous au niveau
politique être des éléments à la
décision je dis ça parce que on voit
bien qu'on est au carrefour
l'autre point que je voulais évoquer et
c'est une question
c'est l'aspect sanitaire on sait tous la
dangereuse dangerosité effectivement et
notre vétérinaire l'a évoqué tout à
l'heure mais vous aussi pour le vivre
dans des toutes productions alimentaires
est une matière vivante et dès lors
qu'on a une concentration importante en
jouissance des conflits qui pourraient
effectivement mettre en situation de
péril des unités de production
donc on concentre le risque
d'alimentation sur un point lorsqu'on a
un élevage le risque est dispersé et sur
la spécialité c'est la même chose il y a
un aspect aussi important qu'il est je
souhaiterais de voir comment il a été
analysé parce qu'effectivement c'est un
point et mes deux dernières remarques
dans l'alimentation je prends l'exemple
de l'alimentation porcine c'est pas
quand même très vieux où on a interdit
toute présence d'antibiotiques dans
l'aliment qui était distribué aux portes
tous les jours avant pour qu'on protège
l'animal systématiquement il y avait des
antibiots donc ma question et ça rejoint
ce qui était évoqué tout à l'heure
est-ce que le risque sanitaire ne
nécessite pas là aussi une présence de
de protection de ces cellules souches on
va alimenter et ma dernière remarque
c'est sur l'honnêteté
parce qu'aujourd'hui quand le veuille ou
non la France et l'Europe a interdit des
OGM et vous en mangez tous les jours
tous les jours parce que dans les
produits dans les ingrédients qui sont
importés et bien il y a d'autres pays et
et ils vous les avez tous les jours et
le sujet je remercie notre chef
effectivement de son propos est-ce que
ça fait partie de l'histoire française
et nous en sommes aussi des héritiers
mais nous devrons aussi le transmettre
et effectivement comment pouvons-nous
protéger cette histoire française
tel qu'on le voit aujourd'hui entre ce
que l'on aurait envie et de en fait ce
qui va effectivement être dans
l'assiette qui est complètement
contraire et en opposition avec nos
envies
on va y arriver merci
merci moi je me place en tant que
consommateur et je ne porte pas de
jugement ni sur la technique ou sur
d'autres aspects je vous avoue qu'en
tant que consommateur et en tant que
sénateur des Français de l'étranger je
suis un petit peu sceptique sur tout ce
que je l'ai entendu et je voudrais poser
une question à Monsieur Marx parce que
d'abord premièrement je pense que c'est
pas un problème de générationnel bon je
sais que j'en consommerai pas il y en a
d'autres qui n'en consommeraient pas
quel que soit la génération faut pas
penser non plus que les gens âgés vont
pas en consommer que les autres vont
consommer mais ça c'est mon avis
personnel moi je voudrais poser une
question à Thierry Marx pour savoir s'il
est prêt demain à mettre dans à partir
du moment on aura l'homologation en
France est-ce qu'il émette est d'accord
pour mettre demain dans l'un de ces
restaurants un plat dans lequel il y
aura de la viande in vitro et je
m'interroge aussi sur l'image que la
gastronomie française pourrait avoir à
l'étranger
à partir du moment où la France est
l'excellence de la France a été reconnu
dans la gastronomie pour aussi bien la
qualité des produits que le service à
l'assiette que nous avons donc
j'aimerais que vous puissiez me répondre
sur ce sujet là
merci madame la Présidente bonjour à
vous quatre merci en tout cas de cette
matinée parce que j'apprends beaucoup de
choses
on a mis le rendu plomb et donc un wokis
puisqu'il est pour le multicultéralisme
des paysages et j'apprends que Daniel a
été à la CGT donc
rien que pour ça je suis content de
mettre lever ce matin et d'avoir fait
une heure et demie de RER bon plus
sérieusement
je sais pas si c'est un enjeu de
génération je crois pas je partage
plutôt ce que je viens de dire ma
collègue
vous avez vu il y a une opposition
plutôt totale
quel que soit notre couleur politique et
je crois qu'elle dit quelque chose sur
la société dans laquelle on vit et dans
laquelle on veut vivre voilà je dis ça
parce que
moi je suis pareil c'est pas mon truc
vous l'aurez compris je pense que
l'alimentation est une vraie question
le plaisir de la table aussi je pense
qu'il faut aussi en parler et ça se voit
d'ailleurs
j'ai plaisir je pense que la question de
l'alimentation pour toutes et tous aussi
est une question vous savez j'habite en
Seine-Saint-Denis et je pense que tout
le monde a droit au bon mais tout le
monde peut pas se le payer aujourd'hui
et une des questions
alors peut-être que vous arriverez à y
répondre c'est que nous allons continuer
à aller vers 10 milliards d'êtres
humains sur la planète et est-ce qu'au
final tout le monde pourra se nourrir et
dans des bonnes conditions aujourd'hui
c'est déjà pas le cas mais est-ce que
c'est votre solution
en tout cas moi c'est peut-être vous y
arriverez parce que vous allez avoir du
financement et on y reviendra d'ailleurs
dis-moi qui te finance on me dira qui
qui tu es quand même il y a une question
autour de ça mais s'il y a tant de
milliards qui sont levés partout dans le
monde sur cette question c'est que le
capital a bien compris que une des
parties pouvait jouer là donc peut-être
qu'on sera tous des idiots dans 10 ans
ou 15 ans qu'on regardera cette audition
mais c'est pas grave et donc moi je
crois d'abord que l'enjeu on doit se le
poser en termes d'alimentation
d'agriculture je sais plus je crois que
c'est Laurent qui le disait mais quand
même et a juste raison
dans un moment où on a des traités de
libre-échange que nous on refuse on peut
avoir le débat parce qu'on se dit que on
est en train de tuer nos agriculteurs
ici et qu'on accepte au moins 10 ans
social et environnementales des produits
qui font quatre fois le tour de la
planète puis là on est en train de nous
vendre un truc bourré aux antibiotiques
et au fongicides bon voilà
est-ce qu'on continue comme ça en tout
cas c'est pas la société dans laquelle
j'ai envie de vivre bon donc je suis en
réflexion je dis pas que voilà il faut
refuser et je partage une question par
contre je pense que la recherche
publique doit y aller à fond
ça oui parce qu'à un moment donné
autrement on aura du décrochage et de
toute façon parce que vous y êtes et
parce que d'autres ils sont dans 10 ans
ça sera un marché et donc si on pouvait
éviter une nouvelle fois d'être à la
traîne ça nous arrangerait donc il faut
qu'il y ait de la recherche publique
qu'on y aille mais en tout cas voilà je
pense que ça nous interroge bien au-delà
sur notre bien manger notre culture
agriculture notre alimentation notre
façon de voir la société et pour
l'instant c'est pas la c'est pas celle
dans laquelle j'ai envie de vivre mais
bon peut-être que dans 20 ans j'aurais
tort
et pour terminer Patricia je suis nager
merci beaucoup il y a quelques années un
français s'est exporté comme on dit
étaler en Israël et à
fonder voilà merci une une un
laboratoire avec Alf farm ouais donc
c'était un des premiers à créer donc le
steak quelques grammes qui coûtait 50
dollars et je voulais je m'interroger
sur le niveau comment on était
compétitif en France par rapport à
d'autres pays parce qu'aujourd'hui c'est
la recherche c'est pas demain qu'on va
manger un steak à 50 g et surtout ce
manque quelques grammes 50 dollars à
quelques grammes vous voulez savoir
comment faire pour garder aussi nos
chercheurs parce que c'est important
comment est-ce que parce qu'en France on
a un savoir-faire on sait à l'INRA
comment est-ce que justement
dans le futur on pourra aussi avoir
nos inventions entre guillemets et je
sais très bien moi je pense que ce sera
pas demain pour mangera ce style de
nourriture mais on est en plein dans la
dans la recherche donc avoir un peu
votre retour au niveau français au
niveau européen et puis au niveau
mondial merci merci juste pour terminer
cette série de questions moi en fait
dans les propos que j'ai entendu se
posent souvent la question du marché en
fait du marché économique du marché qui
sous-tend et du coup ma question elle
est là c'est quoi vos prévisions en fait
dans le monde dans en France avec série
de réticence qu'on entend ici sur les
conséquences sur l'élevage sur le
conséquence sur la gastronomie sur le
plaisir de manger sur quelquefois
l'opposition alimentation et et
nutrition
mais vous puisque vous êtes des startups
je me tourne vers vous votre marché
parce que vous allez sortir un jour de
ce cette ce statut de start-up pour être
dans la dans la vraie vie économique
c'est quoi votre marché j'ai entendu
vous étiez en train de monter une usine
donc voilà en France c'est quoi votre
marché
il y a tellement de questions je compte
aussi sur Nicolas à côté de moi pour
pour se relier pour essayer d'y répondre
ça va être difficile de les de les
prendre dans l'ordre je rebondis déjà
sur sur un élément important je pense
que ça a été posé parmi plusieurs
interventions la bonne perspective pour
se poser les bonnes questions
aujourd'hui sur la viande de culture
c'est qu'est-ce que sera notre monde
notre marché français et le marché
international dans 10 ou 15 ans c'est
faut vraiment qu'on s'extrait
aujourd'hui où on est encore en phase de
recherche ou ces produits sont
complètement nouveaux peu connus etc et
où on a des réticences qui sont
naturelles et se projeter sur dans 10-15
ans quand on sera dans un monde où
l'adaptation réchauffement climatique
deviendra quelque chose de extrêmement
concret sur nos systèmes de production
agricole où on le voit des pandémies se
développent dans nos élevages comment on
va faire face à ça donc le contexte sera
très différent donc il faut beaucoup
d'ouverture aussi imaginez que le monde
sera très différent dans 10 ou 15 ans de
ce qu'il est de ce qu'il est aujourd'hui
voilà élément élément de contexte qui
est rejoint pas mal de choses je peux
pas tout détailler le plaisir de la
table on n'a pas renoncé du tout au
plaisir de la table et Nicolas à côté on
a un exemple avec son foie gras de
culture et nous nos produits seront
d'abord bon ce que de toute façon les
consommateurs n'en mangeront pas si ce
n'est pas bon et on n'a pas non plus
renoncé au plaisir de la table et là
aussi je veux voilà casser une idée
reçue qui ressort une sorte d'opposition
entre l'élevage et ce qu'on est en train
de faire on n'est pas en train de dire
qu'il faut manger de la viande de
culture seulement de la viande de
culture et à la place de l'élevage la
viande de culture c'est une
diversification des sources de protéines
moi je mange je suis très attaché au
territoire très attaché au terroir etc
maintenant très honnêtement quand je
prends une salade César en 20 minutes
devant mon ordinateur le côté
gastronomique et territoires et moins
présent que quand je mange un poulet
rôti le dimanche midi auprès de ma
famille et c'est déjà le cas et
l'idée n'est pas du tout de renoncer à
ça et pareil sur l'opposition entre
l'élevage et nous ce qu'on propose quand
je mange un plat de lentilles je ne suis
pas en train de m'opposer à l'élevage je
ne suis pas en train de dire non à
l'élevage donc là on est une source de
protéines nouvelle etc je voilà pareil
sur le les produits ultra transformés
donc cultive des cellules notre produit
à la fin c'est des cellules il y a pas
de transformation particulière je veux
dire nos modes de production pour faire
très simple parce que ça peut été dit
c'est une grande cuve avec le milieu
nutritif et les cellules intérieures et
à la fin on sépare les cellules du
milieu nutritif on les on les lave pour
qu'il n'y ait plus rien lié au milieu
nutritif qui soit dans les cellules et
donc finalement c'est un procédé qui est
très proche de la production d'une
levure une levure n'est pas un produit
transformé après ça dépend quel produit
final on va faire avec la levure donc le
produit en tant que tel n'est pas un
produit transformé mais peut-être en
priorité répondent sur la question
sanitaire
qui est une et la question de santé
publique qui a une question centrale
évidemment pour nos nouveaux produits
d'abord rappeler que nous ne mettons pas
d'hormones de croissance au sens où on
en a connu dans l'élevage avec des
bovins sous stéroïde etc il y a des
subtilités scientifiques bref ce qui
peut se retrouver et ça dépend encore là
encore des technologies dans les milieux
de culture ce sont des facteurs de
croissance des petites protéines qui
seront éliminées à la fin avec le milieu
de culture donc on n'est pas du tout sur
le même sujet et il ne faut pas du tout
faire d'amalgame entre le bœuf sous
hormones sous stéroïdes et certains
facteurs de croissance qui peuvent se
retrouver dans certains milieux de
culture et il est important de rappeler
que nos produits ont parlé du principe
de précaution seront soumis à une
autorisation préalable de l'ESSA du
européen foot SAFTI agency qui est
peut-être la meilleure agence de
sécurité alimentaire dans le monde selon
un processus long avec un dossier
complexe
pour un processus qui va durer au minima
18 mois et où toutes les questions
seront posées avec les meilleures
spécialistes du monde sur ces sujets là
donc évidemment que les produits qui
arriveront sur le marché français demain
seront des produits dont la sécurité
alimentaire sera garantie et évidemment
l'impact positif aussi sur la nutrition
plus globalement
au travers de ces aspects sanitaires il
y avait également la question des
antibiotiques qui étaient posées
effectivement l'élevage au niveau
mondial c'est plus de 50% de la
consommation des antibiotiques
qu'on consomme en une année évidemment
ça participe à l'antibio-résistance qui
devient un sujet de plus en plus
préoccupant et on en est tous conscients
d'où l'intérêt de développer des
nouveaux modes de production comme
l'agriculture cellulaire où on peut
produire sans utilisation
d'antibiotiques car on est en
environnement contrôlé et dans des
conditions sanitaires extrêmement
irréprochable qui nous permet de voilà
de produire sans antibiotique
[Musique]
oui pour compléter un petit peu je pense
que si on si on catégorise les deux les
deux remarques qu'on a retrouvé dans
beaucoup de questions il y avait la
dimension culturelle et la dimension des
interrogations et des doutes qui
persistaient sur la dimension culturelle
le plaisir de manger la dimension
traditionnelle l'histoire il faut quand
même replacer ça dans le contexte
justement de l'innovation culinaire la
cuisine n'a cessé de se réinventer
l'agriculture n'a cessé de se réinventer
donc pourquoi est-ce que l'agriculture
cellulaire la viande de culture ne
s'intègre pas dans cette histoire et ne
ferait pas partie d'un des chapitres de
cette histoire pas le nouveau chapitre
pas le chapitre ultime du tout mais un
des chapitres en parallèle de tout un
tas d'innovations qui sont aujourd'hui
qui concourent à répondre aux nouvelles
demandes de de citoyens et de notre
société notre société s'appelle gourmet
c'est pour une raison simple c'est qu'on
a mis le goût au coeur de notre démarche
donc tous nos produits ils sont
développés qu'aux développés avec des
experts du monde de la cuisine avec des
chefs avec des restaurateurs qui
soutiennent ces produits là et qui
justement ont continuellement apporté un
éclairage sur le développement de notre
produit et notamment sur notre
alternative au foie là si on a une fois
la culture dans la mission numéro une
est d'apporter aussi un niveau de
plaisir et évidemment de ne pas
représenter une forme de concession sans
pour autant copier évidemment le foie de
la traditionnel auquel nous sommes
s'attacher moi le premier mon associé
est tellement également originaire du
sud-ouest ça évidemment créer des
discussions familiales intenses de son
côté quand ils s'engageait dans ce
projet là mais un petit peu comme les
membres de la commission et Monsieur
Ritman au premier plan au final le
niveau d'information et de connaissances
du sujet amène quelque part une plus
grande ouverture on est consciente c'est
un sujet qui a une dimension quelque
part spectaculaire quelque part
étonnante au premier abord et qui génère
des idées peut-être trop rapidement
rigide sur ce sujet là on est là
justement pour répondre à vos questions
et pour faire toute la lumière sur ce
procédé là qui comme le disait Étienne
Dutoit ressemblera quelque part à
l'échelle de production à une brasserie
dans laquelle on produit de la bière il
faut imaginer des fermenteurs en inox
des tubes en inox dans lesquelles les
cellules seront alimentées au même titre
que des levures qui donnent de la bière
donc cette analogie là elle permet juste
de se figurer un environnement qui n'est
pas encore sur pied mais qui déjà
peut-être permet une forme de
familiarité qui manque aujourd'hui
cruellement à ce sujet là et encore une
fois c'est l'objet de notre présence la
deuxième chose sur la dimension culture
et plaisir justement la méthode de
production de la viande de culture est
une méthode de production on pourrait la
faire de mille façons il y aura des
sociétés qui la feront d'une façon x
donne une façon y les sociétés
américaines à leur façon c'est
l'opportunité pour la France de la faire
de le faire quelque part à la française
avec des objectifs et des standards sur
le goût extrêmement élevé des objectifs
de sourcing sur le substrat également
l'alimentation des cellules extrêmement
élevées et sur l'impact environnemental
parce que là aussi il y a c'est une
question qui est revenue et que
j'aimerais compléter la question du
bilan environnemental est central pour
poser les choses deux sources d'impact
environnemental sur la viande de culture
l'énergie utilisée donc comment est-ce
qu'on va chauffer les bioréacteurs les
fermenteurs et de deux comment est-ce
qu'on va alimenter les cellules donc
pour poser le sujet c'est assez simple
en fonction de nos choix technologiques
en matière d'approvisionnement sur ces
deux sujets là le bilan peut être plus
ou moins favorable au même titre que
pour l'élevage comment est-ce qu'on va
nourrir nos animaux avec des substrats
qui ont nécessité beaucoup d'engrais
azoter ou non
encore ce même type de choix se
présentera pour les acteurs de
l'agriculture cellulaire et nous on
s'engage en tant que société française
qui souhaitent rester en France à faire
les choix les plus vertueux et les plus
profitables à l'écosystème agricole
français auquel on s'intègre
il est un peu trop tôt pour tirer des
conclusions sur l'impact
environnementale et ça je pense que
c'est hyper important aujourd'hui et je
suis vraiment d'accord avec toutes les
conclusions qu'on a vu à droite ou à
gauche dans cette mission il faut
investir dans la recherche notamment sur
cette partie là l'année prochaine notre
premier point de production sera
construit sera en production et on
s'engage à justement à fournir ce qu'on
appelle des analyses en cycle de vie qui
feront la lumière de façon très
factuelle sur l'impact environnemental
et ce sera le cas à tous les stades de
production
gardons juste en tête que c'est une
industrie naissante on ne peut pas
mettre toutes les attentes au niveau le
plus élevé sur cette industrie naissante
les choses iront étape par étape et la
vertu de ce procédé de production ira en
s'améliorant à mesure qu'on apprendra à
faire les choses de manière plus frugale
de manière plus économe de manière plus
locale enfin sur le côté sanitaire on a
parlé du principe de précaution pour
compléter ce que disait Étienne Dutoit
le processus de mise sur le marché qu'on
appelle novel food de nouveaux aliments
en Europe et déjà une application de ce
principe de précaution puisque ce sont
des temps très longs de deux à trois ans
de mise sur le marché ou toute une série
de tests sur à la fois tous les intrants
qui prendront pas au substrat et la fois
tous les résidus éventuels toute la
qualité nutritionnelle du produit fini
sera investiguée et scruté de manière
extrêmement approfondie les produits de
la viande de culture sont parmi les
produits les plus scrutés les plus
analysés pour en garantir justement
l'innocuité et comme Monsieur Dutoit
nous n'utilisons aucun antibiotique et
nous n'utilisons pas d'hormones de
croissance ça c'est quand même assez
important de le préciser on peut faire
sans et justement peut-être le faire à
la française c'est le faire de cette
façon et en tout cas c'est comme ça que
chez gourmet nous le faisons
n'hésite pas à préciser si tu si tu
souhaites non j'étais plus sur
effectivement rebondir sur sur cet
aspect viande de culture à la française
et je pense que c'est vraiment le point
fondamental qu'on doit qu'on doit qu'on
doit proposer aujourd'hui et ça rebondit
sur une autre thématique qui a été
évoquée celle des mastodontes de la
viande etc est-ce qu'il y a pas un
risque de concentration etc
ma réponse elle est claire les ma
sodomes de la viande ils existent déjà
aux États-Unis etc dans des systèmes
économiques tels que les États-Unis il
est probable qu'il reproduisent ce
qu'ils connaissent déjà ici en France ma
conviction c'est que ça va être
différent de ce point de vue là voilà
moi je vous l'ai dit je suis monté par
le groupe Remo qui est une ti qui est
complètement intégré dans notre système
agricole aujourd'hui moi ma Vocation
c'est d'être producteur d'un ingrédient
du poulet cultivé et je discute avec les
systèmes coopératifs avec les boîtes
agroalimentaires qui
sont dans nos territoires que vous
connaissez tous pour faire des produits
finaux des plats cuisinés en utilisant
mon ingrédient donc on s'intègre
complètement dans une filière
agroalimentaire existante et dans un
système économique diversifié comme il
l'est aujourd'hui de même sur la sur le
l'approvisionnement des nutriments on
travaille avec un producteur de milieu
de culture français et voilà et donc il
y a une possibilité de créer une filière
française une filière à la française
avec les acteurs actuels de
l'agroalimentaire qui seront partis
prenantes de ce système là
très bien laissez la parole voilà au
directeur de recherche
un point concernant les antibiotiques
j'ai lu une publication internationale
écrite par différentes entreprises
certes pas françaises mais qui disait
quand même que
l'utilisation d'antibiotiques était
possible ou probable probablement à des
niveaux inférieurs comparativement à
l'élevage mais que
l'exclusion totale des antibiotiques
c'est pas si évident que ça
un deuxième point concernant la
communication je suis tout à fait
d'accord qu'il faut évidemment
communiquer et expliquer le processus de
fabrication mais je suis moins d'accord
avec l'idée que expliquer le processus
de fabriquer à Sion en prennent
forcément une meilleure acceptation
c'est pas du tout évident
selon la façon dont on présente les
choses etc etc et évidemment ça m'amène
à plaider une nouvelle fois pour les
questions de transparence
et si vous avez effectivement une unité
de production
je serai ravi si vous pouviez
communiquer non seulement les analyses
de cycle de vie mais également les
données brutes qui ont servi à ces
analyses de cycle de vie dans une
politique de sciences ouvertes qui est
mise en avant aujourd'hui par la
Communauté européenne
encore deux petits points très
importants
évidemment cette problématique doit être
abordée dans toutes ces dimensions non
seulement techniques mais aussi
environnementales culturel social etc
etc et dans un organisme de recherche
comme inrae qui comprend au total 12000
personnes il y a 14 départements de
recherche plus ou moins enfin orientée
soit sur les aspects techniques soit sur
les aspects d'alimentation humaine soit
sur les aspects de sciences sociales et
on a la capacité de conduire ce qu'on
appelle une expertise collective et j'en
arrive au dernier point
sur commande du ministère de
l'agriculture ou sur comment de des élus
que vous êtes notre institution peut se
saisir effectivement d'un dossier
d'expertise collective pour analyser la
dimension toutes les dimensions de cette
problématique mais pour l'instant ça n'a
pas été le cas donc pour l'instant
quelques recherches quelques chercheurs
comme moi s'intéressent à cette question
mais l'institution n'a pas été saisie
d'une demande formelle soit du
gouvernement soit des élus d'avoir une
expertise collective dans toutes ces
dimensions en mobilisant tous les
experts dans les différents domaines que
j'ai cités
je vous remercie très bien on va laisser
conclure par Monsieur Marx et d'avance
je vous remercie voilà de ces débats de
ces questions
qui ne sont qu'au début
merci merci de me laisser conclure je
suis
touché de le faire alors je vais essayer
de le faire de façon bicéphale soit je
réponds de façon
appartenant à la chair universitaire
Paris Saclay sur la cuisine du futur et
l'alimentation du futur et dans ce
cas-là je me dis bah continue observer
cherchons il y a pas de raison que la
France soit à la traîne là-dessus si je
réponds en tant qu'artisan artisan
cuisinier lié à la gastronomie je
réponds même assez attriste de façon
assez simple oui non je pardon je n'en
mettrai pas à ma carte
mais je vais le faire je ne pourrais pas
empêcher que ce produit existe je vais
répondre pourquoi je le mettrai pas à ma
carte parce que je vais servir dans
cette gastronomie que des ultras
possédants que des ultras riches
parce que on aura protégé et ça je crois
pas qu'on puisse
le faire disparaître on va protéger les
petits élevages les petits faiseurs les
les petits producteurs seront
extrêmement protégés parce que pourront
vendre leurs prix pas au prix mais à la
valeur et puis on va continuer et ça va
exister cette ce qu'on appelle cette
viande et tous les éléments de langage
sont là gourmets France Origine France
Garantie sanitaire et là on va continuer
et je vous fiche mon billet quand on
commence à lever des sommes comme 60
millions de dollars ou d'euros peu
importe 100 millions on voit bien que
c'est pour qui c'est pour répondre à
cette alimentation à deux vitesses
vous avez une alimentation pour les gens
qui vont bien qui peuvent payer qu'on va
rester à vivre suffisant et une
alimentation depuis les années 70 pour
les gens qui vont pas bien et qui ont un
reste à vivre très faible donc
l'industrie agroalimentaire qui était un
darwinisme pur s'adapte il faut faire
moins de viande il faut être plus
environnementale donc on vous sort tous
les mots d'impact environnemental et on
vous dit ça va être merveilleux on va
faire des pots de prix en l'occurrence
renoncé à la qualité et on vous fera à
manger à moindre coût vous avez renoncé
à la qualité alors on vous fait un
dépiprix c'est encore la théorie du low
cost avec les mêmes éléments de langage
que nous avons dû à partir des années 70
renoncer à la qualité on vous fait des
petits prix et aujourd'hui l'industrie
s'était emparée de ça la grande
distribution s'est emparée de ça et puis
on y met évidemment des forces comme
vous l'avez dit monsieur le sénateur de
marketing extrêmement forte extrêmement
puissante mais ce type de projet et
encore une fois si je me range en tant
que chercheur là ça m'intéresse je me
dis oui allons voir il pas de raison que
la France soit à la traîne de ça mais de
toute façon à un moment donné on ne
pilotera plus on pourra ça sera comme
les OGM on va se dire non non c'est à
nos frontières mais non et ce qui
m'inquiète c'est la perte de culture et
la manipulation des masses sur
l'alimentation plus vous allez appauvrir
les masses en termes de culture moins
elle connaîtront ce qu'elles ont à
manger plus vous les manipulerez donc
c'est une perte d'identité
d'identité locale d'identité nationale
pour rentrer vers une alimentation
mondialisée et normalisée je peux me
tromper mais par expérience ce que
j'apprends avec les chercheurs de Paris
Saclay étudie d'abord le passé pour voir
le présent et entrevoir l'avenir mais le
passé m'apprend que l'argent
l'argent et ce côté
très darwiniste du monde capitaliste
disons-le et bien s'adapte et
aujourd'hui il faut faire une industrie
agroalimentaire avec de la viande
ultra transformée et bien allons-y et on
y mettra les éléments de langage qu'il
faut je trouve que personnellement je
peux me tromper je peux être le has-been
de service mais c'est une boîte de
Pandore et on a plutôt intérêt à essayer
de contenir un peu cette boîte de
Pandore mais quand on voit évidemment
les sommes qui sont levées et quand
j'entends d'une représentation de l'état
de toute façon l'Europe décidera il va
être très difficile d'expliquer à aux
gens que nous fréquentons au quotidien
que l'Europe peut décider du contenu de
mon assiette parce que ils ont la
puissance de l'argent
c'est dérangeant c'est une perte
d'identité nationale qui moi
personnellement me dérange alors pour
répondre à la sénatrice non je n'en
servirai pas je n'aurais pas à le faire
parce que la gastronomie française va
devenir une toute petite gastronomie
réservée au plus initiés mais pour
initier les gens à la gastronomie il
faut commencer à l'école et de commencer
entrevoir le mangeur de demain donc moi
je milite aujourd'hui pour comprendre ce
qu'on mange pour refaire le mangeur
plutôt que le consommateur et le
surconsommateur ça c'est ça me paraît
être une démarche pour moi qui est
essentielle de se dire et bah oui
regardons maîtrisons parce que la
recherche française doit continuer à
maîtriser ça mais le risque c'est et
vous le savez comme moi ça va nous
échapper comme notre agriculture vous
voyez déjà et je termine mon propos
n'oublions pas et on a parté on a parlé
d'agroécologie et avec le système pardon
bleu blanc coeur nous avons défini ce
qui était un bon produit
son impact social son impact
environnemental et son impact
nutritionnel ça ça a du sens pour moi et
on voit bien que le monde agricole
contre le reconsidée en tant que paysan
mais pas comme simplement fournisseur de
minerai il redevient paysan il a des
économies beaucoup plus symbiotiques et
beaucoup plus proche et finalement il
devient acteur d'une France qui est
capable de produire de bons produits
pour tous moi ce qui m'intéresse avec ce
type d'action comme bloboker c'est
d'être aussi bien à la Grande Épicerie
de Paris où on sait que c'est quand même
pas le plus abordable mais aussi dans la
grande distribution de permettent à des
personnes d'avoir accès à un bon produit
[Musique]